لو انت مو راسلنا في العزيز في موسكو
عندنا ثلاث صور بدنا اياك تعلقنا عليه عدد
الجواد هسه الصوره
لما نزلت درجات الحراره الى مستوى متدني
جميع بطاريات الكاميرات تتوقف عن العمل
[موسيقى]
والسبيل الوحيد للخروج عبر الهواء مباشره
هو جهاز الهاتف
والدرجات كبيره وهي احد اللقطات اللي كنت
فيه انا على الهواء سهام
اوه ههه
طيب هون يعني كميات كبيره من الثلوج نحنا
بنشهدها عاده بحلول شهر مارس
الاخبار الموصل
40 50 سم مرتفعه عن الارض وكميات كبيره
يبقى لما بتوقفي هيك بالطريق لمده 20 30
ثانيه
ابيض طبعا بس احنا بنحب سقوط الثلج لانه
سقوط الثلج بيروح البرد نوع المصيبه عندما
تشرق الشمس في موسكو يتحول الجو الى صقيع
قاسي رياح قويه تزداد سرعات بشكل كبير
وتخيلي سهام يعني الوقوف على الهواء كاع
مراسل عمل ميداني خلال ثلاث اربع دقائق
تفقد الاحساس بكافه حواس الجسم
المباشر مضطر انت تسحب المكرفون لانه ايدك
تكون جنبه تكون جميله
اه انت الصبح مضطر في البيت لازم تكون
مهتم شكلك
كويس توصل لعند سيارتك بتلاقيها بهذا
المشهد اكيد تتعرف عليها
مضطر انت تفتح السياره
مضطره تنظفها شويه
ما بعرف بشوف لحتى تقدر تطلع الفرشايه
وبقعد عمليه تنظيف السياره تستمر عشر
دقائق 15 دقيقه 20 دقيقه دقيقه
جوعان وصلت للسياره كله بيضه وانا بذكرها
كويس اه بدي افتح الباب صعب حتى يعني كبسه
السياره ما عم تشتغل بلشنا نظيف بالسياره
بايدي وقعت وقمت بالشنطه قام طلعت عم ننظف
سياره مو سياره
تنظيف سيارات الجيران يعني